[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah we're
still alive
[Laughter]
after actually we had a really good
friday night yeah we didn't go out last
night no we didn't yeah we didn't go out
last night we were resting i think i
fell asleep at like 10 30 last night we
were watching like unsolved mysteries
and i was like
but you know but yeah we had a good time
friday night though yeah we watched this
one
last night yeah yeah we watched this one
last night you know what's we okay so i
know one of you guys probably you
kanavatsalam because you were saying uh
how you like this movie could have been
better but it's a good watch uh yeah i
agree with that this was actually like
pretty decent i was actually gonna do
this show because
um you guys had recommended it i was
actually gonna do it on my
on my show
because it was on hulu for a while but
then when i went to watch it it wasn't
on hulu anymore and i was like okay well
[ __ ] that must have taken it down but um
well now it's on amazon prime they moved
it over to amazon prime
and it's on the free to me thing so i
was just kind of like it's weird because
they have two versions on there i
clicked on the one and it was like a pay
or you had to uh subscribe to epics or
something like that but then they had
one that was free to me so i'm just like
okay whatever you really gotta like
watch with the amazon thing the gimmick
to this movie is haunted house
underneath the water
which i'm amazed has not been done
before yeah they have to scuba dive
through it
and uh it looks really good
it really looks like a house underneath
the water in the bottom of a lake
and um
i guess it was a set but it looked real
yeah well yeah i'll um because i was
kind of curious how they did that too
yeah
uh it was real it's not a real house but
it's i mean
it's a real set of a house they built a
house that was on a grid system yeah so
they could uh lower different parts of
the house down into the water like while
they were filming it okay they filmed it
at this big studio in belgium
which is known for their big huge like
30-foot water tank that's like where
they film a lot of underwater movies
and so yeah they built they actually
built the house and you know whatever
part of the house they were filming in
they would lower it under the water
and both of the main actors that were in
it had to go through this intensive like
scuba diving training and all this other
kind of stuff um because they did shoot
the entire thing
underwater which like i said
goes underwater that's pretty [ __ ]
impressive and like i said it's just i
don't know it's it
it makes it like creepier
yeah ghosts underwater
apparitions
possessions underneath the water
uh just spooky haunted house
[ __ ] floating in the water in the house
it looks really cool um
it really didn't pull me in at first it
kind of the the the beginning wasn't uh
it didn't start really kind of the way
it had to start to pull me in i would
kind of
lose
the
track of the movie and it would lose my
attention
i don't i don't know if it was a problem
with a movie or a problem with my
mindset at the time
it looked like a good movie
parts of it was like wow that's that's
pretty good but i just really wasn't
feeling it
watch it i'd have to see it again i
think
yeah i mean the gimmick of it if you
want to call it that um is actually like
a really really good one and honestly
all of this stuff being underwater like
i said makes it a lot creepier plus you
have the added
um kind of thing where you know you're
underwater and you can like potentially
run out of air so it's kind of like a
time crunch also
um you know yeah it's like i i can see
what you're saying it's like this wasn't
like the best movie ever but
it did have some really cool visuals and
i just thought it was like a really
really good idea and it kept my
attention the whole time it's not super
long i think it was only like 86 minutes
um
the ending was kind of surprising i
didn't really wanna i don't really want
to spoil it but yeah i didn't realize
when i was watching this this was
written and directed by the same two
guys uh julian mori and alexandra
bustillo or bustillo
those are the same two guys that did the
very famous um
new french extremity movie inside they
all which is [ __ ] up uh and they also
did one called livid
and um i think they did one that's on
shutter i think and it's i think it's
called candicia or something like that
but i haven't seen that one i've heard
that one was pretty good i think that
they kind of busted out with
inside which came out in 2007 which was
like a really notorious like really
[ __ ] up movie and they've kind of been
trying to like
you know make another one that's as well
regarded as that since then
and it's kind of been all over the place
but
you know uh so this one is not it's not
really gory at all it's nothing this one
is more like spooky
you know just like the whole visual of
it is spooky so the story is basically
there's a couple
ben and tina and this is a french movie
but it's mostly in english like
sometimes like some of the people speak
french because it takes place in france
but most of it's in english because like
the main guy uh
the guy that plays ben is british so
they're a couple and they're kind of
like youtube like urbex type people
so at the beginning because i kind of
feel like some places said that this is
found footage which i guess it
technically is starts off feeling like
found footage it is kind of like found
footage but
when they get to the deep house it
doesn't really seem like a found footage
movie even though i guess technically it
is because it's supposedly filmed from
their drone or you know their cameras
that they're using
but it doesn't feel like a found footage
movie once they get to that right and
actually like the in between stuff the
very first part of it is because they're
kind of establishing hey these are urbex
explorers they're in some uh sanitarium
like an abandoned sanitarium and they're
so they're just kind of like trying to
set up that that's what these this
couple does they just post these this
stuff on youtube and the guy ben is
really really concerned about we need to
you know the next big thing so we get
all these views because they're trying
to make money off the channel
so they want to like find something that
nobody's done before
so to that end uh you know after that
little beginning found footage part
that's in the sanitarium
then they're like okay well we found
this place in southwest france and it's
like really remote and there's
supposedly this
well see okay now the place that they
were initially gonna go was like
a town that had been
purposely flooded
uh you know to build like a dam or
something like that
and so they're like oh that should be
really cool it'll be like a whole little
town like underwater but then when they
get there it's turns out that it's like
a big tourist area so it's not like
secret at all
but then this dude named pierre who
lives around there says hey um you know
yeah this place is kind of all crawling
with tourists but there's another part
of the lake that nobody knows about
and that place there's just one house
and it's under it's at the bottom of the
lake and it's perfectly preserved and
nobody really knows about it and for a
small fee i will take you out there and
you can dive down to the bottom and
explore it and film it for your channel
so
they're all excited and that's kind of
what well ben more than tina because i
feel like tina is really not she seems
like she's not real experienced diver so
she's like really really nervous like
this is going to be like her first big
dive and everything
and uh so yeah so they pretty much
so like the first 20 30 minutes is kind
of like setting that up
and then you know they go down to the
house and the rest of the movie takes
place
inside this house underwater uh with
them exploring this house and creepier
and creepier [ __ ] happens and they can't
get out and they're running out of air
and that's just pretty much how it goes
it's a pretty simple
story there is they do find out like the
backstory behind the house which like i
said this is a fairly new movie so i
don't really want to spoil it too much
but there is a backstory behind the
movie um that becomes clearer like the
more they explore it you know what i'm
saying
but uh but yeah i mean this is
definitely worth watching like i said
i kind of feel like toward the end
um
because this has like a found footage
aspect to it
some of the [ __ ] that happens it's not
super clear
what happens because sometimes the
camera's moving around and there's
bubbles and it's dark um so you're not
entirely sure you're like well okay what
what is going on
so there's a little bit of that and i do
kind of feel like um
you know the the woman that was uh
playing tina was just kind of kind of
kept yelling for him the whole time
because they had a microphone where they
could hear each other like in their
tanks or whatever the helmets
and uh so she was just kind of like
screaming his name like the whole time
which got a little bit annoying but
other than that
i don't know this was actually a pretty
decent watch i just really really liked
i mean i love haunted house movies
anyway
um you know if they're done well it's
probably my favorite sub genre of horror
and
like i said i'm just kind of amazed that
nobody thought to do a haunted house
movie like underwater before
maybe i don't know i guess it's not the
most obvious thing i guess the most
obvious thing would be like a shipwreck
has anybody done a horror movie set like
in a shipwreck
entirely i guess not
maybe for the reason that would be super
difficult there was death shift
trail that was a haunted ship yeah but
it wasn't like underwater that's what
i'm saying
no because you would think that but like
i said maybe it's not the most obvious
thing it's like it's just amazes me that
nobody thought of it
up until now well like i said maybe
because because it was a huge technical
undertaking that they actually but i
like that they had the balls to actually
film the whole [ __ ] thing underwater
yes it was in a tank they didn't do it
an actual lake or anything but
the fact that they actually had the
actors learn to dive and they built a
house and submerged it and then they
filmed the whole thing like that rather
than just
faking it because you can't do that
whereas like you could make it look
underwater but they actually did it
underwater
there was it
it looked good there were aspects of it
that kind of reminded me of a video game
i once played a long time ago in the
2000s i think it was called torque
or the main character was named torque
and it was about you play this guy
who um wakes up and in prison
for i guess killing your family
but then you find out you might be crazy
and it's kind of like you're fighting
all these things in this centerium and
this prison and [ __ ]
and i guess the whole thing is a
hallucination
but there's a couple scenes where
a psychiatrist is talking to you through
a [ __ ] film camera in a
studio in a
operating room and something like that
kind of happens in this movie where a
ghost comes out of a [ __ ]
film screen underneath the water it
looked good it reminded me of that video
game
yeah i really i liked that shot yeah i
liked that shot there was also another
shot
where
that where they swim into
like i guess it was a dining room or
something and the candelabra was like
suspended and i was like i wonder if
they got that idea from the haunted
mansion
like the disney haunted mansion because
remember in the haunted mansion i don't
know if the one in california is like
this but the one in florida has i think
it's i think it's the same but you kind
of your car turns like that and you see
like that endless uh hallway yeah that
goes on forever and there's a candelabra
like floating both have them in the
middle yeah that's what i thought i
thought they both have that because i
have a big difference between all those
between the rides i've been through both
and i grew up with the one out in
california went on it many times
but they also have changed them over the
years yeah they've added the the
the california one
certain parts of us i remember it as
being bigger
it may be like when you went outside
into the dam
uh
uh when you went in into the graveyard
it was bigger than the california one i
also remember there's a big ass there
used to be a big old [ __ ] spider on a
web that you pass and uh that's in the
florida one too is it
okay and that spider was like the size
of a dog at least
i think well the florida one i think
there was more than one spider because i
think there was it's when you go up the
stairs and you kind of like turn around
and go upstairs i think like over the
stairs there's like this all these
cobwebs if i'm remembering correctly
it's been a while but i think when we
did that dark disney show a while back i
think we talked a lot about the honda
mansion because i got super obsessed
with the differences between i did like
ride-alongs on youtube and it's like i
read a bunch of books about just the
concepts and stuff right yeah yeah okay
i think it looks a little bit different
but not that different it's pretty much
the same
and then have the little the little
ghost woman going come back
don't become
bad don't forget to bring your death
certificate
that's a [ __ ] and you look at it and
it's about this big and the [ __ ] face
is moving on it it projected some
projector [ __ ] face on it it looked
good yeah
but yeah i mean
i don't know i'm just like amazed that
this that this concept has never really
like uh been done before amelia american
military 100 says hauntings in space
like event horizon are even rarer than
haunted ships that's true yeah because
they don't work that well if you ask me
well
haunted house in space i mean i kind of
feel like alien did that and that's not
a really haunted house
yeah it's just a horror movie it's a
monster movie really but
the
you know the kind of concept of it was
as though it was like a haunted house in
space and event horizon
i like event horizon but
it's got i don't know it's got some
problems but i do like it um
i don't know to me
i'm not hugely hugely into like sci-fi
i like some of it and i like some of the
horror sci-fi crossovers but to me like
[ __ ] that's in space i know this is
weird but like [ __ ] that's in space is
not as scary to me as [ __ ] that's
underwater you know what i mean like so
if you're gonna set a movie like
underwater with like [ __ ]
sharks or big fish or like a haunted
house that's gonna be like way scarier
to me than space i'm not entirely sure
why that is because it's like i'd be too
scared to go to space i'm admitting like
right now but that movie underwater was
good it flopped at the theater but i
thought i loved it it was like something
out of it something out of alien like it
was kind of like a ridley scott type
movie but it turns out you're watching
it it's lovecraft man it's gotten
cthulhu down there
which he might be that's what i mean
almost yeah i think it definitely yeah i
mean they didn't say it like that but
yeah i'm pretty sure that that's what
they were getting at and um it was just
this big ass [ __ ] sea monster
and they were
deep sea drilling down on this [ __ ]
deep sea rig in the future it was like
something out of blade runner
and that [ __ ] started flying apart
because they were [ __ ] around and
drilling down to where [ __ ] where the
old ones live waking up cthulhu
what's her name kristen what's her name
kristen sarah cohen's kristen stewart
and that was i thought she did great in
that i don't know her from anything else
i uh uh so i didn't she was like well
she was in you know she was in that
movie the runaways she played joan jett
she was [ __ ] she was actually great
in that that was that's a good movie
you'd probably like it actually yeah
um
because i saw it a while back
slasher fred says there's a
family-friendly haunted house movie i've
seen many times called mr boogety i kind
of remember that one i think i only saw
it once or twice
um i'd have to kind of uh watch that
again it's one of those wonderful world
of disney movies yeah that's right
that's right yeah it kind of [ __ ]
disney
that's old though mr boogity is an old
it's an old movie yeah because i
remember what was that 86 88 i want to
say it was back in the 80s they've been
they've been dropping the ball [ __ ]
for a long time now
slasher fred says one of my haunted
house movies is the watcher in the woods
yeah that's a good one too that's
another one that i kind of would like to
rewatch because i haven't seen that in a
long time yeah kanavatsan says this
movie must have been expensive i'm not
really sure
how much it cost that's kind of what i
was thinking too i was like man if that
i was like that before i found out that
they actually like how they actually did
it like that they built the house set
and then submerged it in a tank and i
was just kind of like
me i was like man is that fake did they
do it really did not look fake and i
guess you know i was trying to think is
did they cgi the whole thing but i was
like that really doesn't look like they
know
yeah so when i found out it was real
yeah i was just like how much [ __ ]
money did that cost to make holy [ __ ]
that's what i mean that's why maybe as
much as you think maybe not i mean
maybe it would have been more expensive
to do the whole thing in
uh
in cg yeah what was that other
underwater movie that we saw in the
theater with the sharks in it 47 meters
down uncaged that's right something like
that yeah those weren't bad yeah that
was those were pretty good yeah we got
those cenotes yeah where they were down
in the caves and stuff yeah i don't know
if they actually did because usually
what they would do i think nowadays um
is that if they have a movie like that
where it's mostly like underwater [ __ ] i
think they'll do some of it in actual
tanks or whatever but most of it they'll
just kind of like cgi it
yeah because i kind of feel like even
the movie underwater with kristin
stewart i think some of the shots of
them like walking across the sea floor
and stuff like that i don't think they
were actually underwater it worked
though yeah it looked like they were but
i think that they did it like with cg
yeah um but yeah this one absolutely you
can tell this is absolutely not cgi like
every
like i said they have all the gear on
and it's like all the bubbles and
everything and it does not look fake by
any stretch of the imagination so that
just kind of blows my mind that they did
that so
really i mean
you know even though
it could have been a little i don't know
like i really liked a lot of the imagery
in this i thought the imagery was really
creepy and i really really like
um
oh i liked the music in it too like the
music and the score
you know what i mean like remember that
there was one part in it where
uh kind of the supernatural [ __ ] started
happening and the guy ben he had like
this thing on his wrist that controlled
his air tank and he also and also
controlled the drone that was going
around the drone's name was tom by the
way yeah that's what he called it uh so
he could control the drone
with his uh wrist thing
and uh so they had that going on and he
could play music on it
and at one point like supernatural [ __ ]
started to ensue and the music came on
and it was like that creepy was that um
i think the song is called you don't own
me but it was like a french version
and then it like got all creepy and
distorted so like just hearing that song
like underwater when there's like all
this creepy [ __ ] going on it's just i
don't know i thought the use of music
was like really good in it as well and
like the score i really really dug that
and actually the opening song what the
[ __ ] was the name of that song
um because i think you even said that
the opening song yeah i like that yeah i
didn't know what it was either but yeah
it this one had some really really good
uh music in it as well so there was
always that but yeah if you have amazon
prime you can watch it for free on there
like i said there's two versions and one
of them says that you have to sign up
for epics
um to get it but you don't there's
another version on there that is uh free
to watch so
yeah i mean if you like haunted house
movies it's definitely worth watching i
thought it was like really cool like i
said it had some really cool imagery i
really like
i don't know i just really i know this
is a weird thing to say but i guess like
i'm a graphic designer so i really like
certain visual things i really like that
color grading thing they do where
there's kind of like a teal or green
kind of thing and then there's like all
this warm
like yellow and orange like in the
foreground you know what other movie did
that too that like i really really dug
was um
that anthology movie the mortuary
collection i think it was called that
was on shutter and they did the same
thing too where they had like all this
all the backgrounds and stuff were like
all this tealy kind of green and then
like they had all these like little warm
flickering like candle warm tones and i
just really like that juxtaposition i
don't know i just like i like that
visual i don't know why that is but um
rick shaw says i read there's a sequel
to underwater possibly in the works oh
good man that would be good because that
[ __ ] flopped and it shouldn't well the
weird thing about that movie yeah and
we've talked about this before is that i
kind of feel like well january isn't a
big movie going month i guess and they
kind of dumped it in january
and the weird thing about it though is
that even though a lot of people didn't
see it in the theater like when it came
out like on streaming
a bunch of horror fans saw it and were
like oh man that was really good like so
i kind of feel like it was one of those
movies that slipped on the radar yeah
like nobody thought it was going to be
any good but then kind of word of mouth
helped it out i think i just saw the uh
the trailer for the new fire starter it
looked good
that's right i forgot that they were
remaking yeah look good i mean i don't
have a problem
you know gotta see we'll see how it
works out yeah i mean the i like the
original one but i mean the original one
came out a long time ago and honestly
you know you could do
and technically it's not even really a
remake of the movie because it's just
another adaptation of the novel yeah you
know we'll see what if you want to be
i don't know who's doing it i just saw
the trailer and went oh that looked
pretty good
i'll have to yeah i haven't seen the
trailer i did hear that they were
remaking it but i haven't uh like i said
that's
that doesn't bother me sometimes like
remakes i'm just kind of like oh [ __ ]
why are we remaking that but
i don't i don't think i would mind
seeing that remade
well
what i liked about that book and the
movie is it wasn't just about her it was
about her dad yeah her dad had abilities
too he could do what was called the push
where he had basically the jedi mind
trick
he could get you to even kill yourself
that's how good but um the more he did
it the more it [ __ ] caused brain
aneurysms so he couldn't
do it forever his nose had started
bleeding and stuff it eventually killed
him
but he had to do it to save his daughter
they were trying to get her because she
had pyrokinesis yeah which is a modified
form of telekinesis instead of moving
objects
you just accelerate molecular motion and
molecules move faster and faster until
things burst into flames which has been
reported in poltergeist cases i believe
it
based launch you know it's interesting
that poltergeist book that i wrote a
long time ago
um
[Music]
apparently i don't know if stephen king
like did a lot of like research into
this with fire starter but a lot of
poltergeist activity that involves
little girls has that has yeah fire
starting yeah that's apparently like a
big thing i've seen it with like there
are some cases where it was little boys
but it's almost always girls and it's
unusual [ __ ] it's just that they'll find
like a burn spot
on the on the wall
you know where the wallpaper was
out of reach just
and then over time it might be a little
bigger and then in another place of
[ __ ] it might sprout out flames and
actually people have to put it out
and then sometimes it was just clothes
catching on fire inside the dressers
just
yeah why not if objects can move rspk
can happen which i've seen
if that can happen then that means
[ __ ] pyrokinesis is it would be
easier actually it would be easier
because not moving anything big you're
just moving molecules making them
agitate faster
like that russian woman who could move
[ __ ] objects through the glass
or kill a mouse by looking at it and
that was a little [ __ ]
and you think that that shit's bull that
[ __ ] was not [ __ ] the army and
[ __ ] the army had invested in that
[ __ ] to try to figure out how it worked
and
they closed it down but i just heard
that they just reopened it under
something else and i know they were
trying to figure out how it was that
some guys were really good at spotting
an ambush
they had them go through this vr thing
virtual re and it didn't have to be a
real ambush could be just a fake ambush
through vr goggles and some guys had a
higher percentage of predicting when
actors would jump out and and pretend to
shoot at him
and they were trying to identify those
guys and put him in the [ __ ]
as point man and vehicle convoys
but then you wonder
is that psychic or is it mentalism
is you know what i mean
is this is the subconscious identifying
that yeah this would be a good place to
hide
but there are good places to hide
everywhere
it's so
how is it they're doing it
but according to the us army last i
heard there were some certain guys that
were like
40 percent better at it than the average
people
yeah yeah
so it's out there
um let's see kind of awesome says i want
to see morbius i heard it was bad
yeah i've kind of heard a lot of
i mean i haven't really watched any
reviews of it or anything but i've heard
like a lot of people were disappointed
in it i'm not really sure
um i don't you know i don't know i'm not
recently i'm not up on the uh the thing
and then evidently the only thing that
was good was batman
yeah kind of uh says batman's also good
like the crow in a way because they're
talking about um the dude that played
pennywise and it is cast for the crow
reboot so they might be rebooting oh
that might be true yeah that seems like
another one that might be good
yeah they could reboot that yeah that
might be the right guy to do that too
american military 100 says haunted ships
may be scary but trust me there's
nothing more horrifying than living on a
vessel with a bunch of u.s sailors lol
especially when there's no lube right oh
god
[Laughter]
that is scary gotcha hugo says hi guys
never seen this movie it's actually on
it was on hulu but i don't think it is
anymore it's on amazon prime and you can
watch it for free if you have amazon
prime um and it's totally worth watching
like we've discussed it but
it's basically like a haunted house
movie but it's
a house that's under water
and they did actually shoot the whole
thing underwater and it's pretty
impressive i didn't love it but it was
pretty damn good it was pretty damn good
it kept my interest uh it was really
creepy there was like some really creepy
[ __ ] going on it was a great [ __ ]
concept so you know
that's all i can say about it i don't
you know like i said it's kind of new so
i don't really want to like ruin it for
people
even though like i said other than after
the first 30 minutes like when they get
into the house it's pretty much just
them
exploring this house and creepy [ __ ]
happening and them not being able to get
out you know and them running out of air
so that's pretty much the whole entire
movie it's not like a complicated story
or anything and like i said they do get
into like the backstory of the house and
everything like that but um
yeah
steven seagal should have been the
penguin hahaha in the batman
he would make a good he would make a
good penguin
he's a little steven seagal he's too big
he's too big to be the penguin right
well [ __ ] steven seagal is [ __ ]
like he's he's big he's like six two i
think he's a big dude penguin's gotta be
a little bitty guy
danny devito was a good favorite
that's true yeah they could make it work
they maybe they could like they could
have him just walk around on his knees
all the time and just shoot him and just
shoot him from the belly up the original
penguin was just meredith
yeah that's right hey wait burgess
meredith was the was the penguin from
the tv show oh that's right hey batman
for some reason i thought he was the
riddler no he was not who the [ __ ] was
the riddler then uh [ __ ] now i can't
remember
god damn it it's been so long since i've
said that
and then uh
caesar romero was the joker
oh i remember that i remember that
i remember that yeah
rick shaw says i watched the john wayne
gacy tapes today good if you like true
crime yeah i've been wanting to watch
that i guess i gotta kind of be in the
mood for it
um for some reason i lost my connection
was that what that noise was yeah i'm
just restarting it just okay it's not
showing up
but you know it's uh i guess it's not
putting out down there it's not putting
out
you got it connected with a with a cable
so
yeah we don't usually the internet's
been so much better
i mean i think since we've since we've
had the ethernet cable yeah the my
hundred foot one that goes all the way
down to like downstairs i'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] reroute this [ __ ] man
eventually i mean it is kind of
ridiculous we don't leave it hooked up
like that because it would just look
like a big mess yeah because like i said
it's 100 feet long yeah and so it goes
all the way out here all the way down
the stairs all the way through the
kitchen and all the way like to the
living room
and you know
but
since we've had that
i think one time we were doing a live
stream and it kind of like we lost the
connection like for a second or like a
few seconds yeah but ever since then
that's the only time that's happened i
don't think we've had and because
remember all the problems we were having
before like before we had the the cable
so it actually really did help like i
said 15 bucks and it just pretty much
solved all the problems i got uh i got a
connection back
i've honestly been having um i always
have trouble i was watching a movie on
shutter earlier and i kept losing the
connection it kept going low resolution
and then it would like go off for like
10 seconds or 20 seconds and then it
would come back and
it just kept doing that like the whole
time i was trying to watch the [ __ ]
movie
american military talking about being on
the ship with the sailors and i just had
to say how dare you
how dare you ever
are we are we
and that's all he had to say about it
yeah but can he put something up in his
[ __ ] booty
and christopher walking with his [ __ ]
naked legs is on the side like that he
looks back at the aliens because how
dare you
i [ __ ] bust it up well it's it's
funny that movie
that would be something else we talked
about that a few weeks back
well because the thing about christopher
walken is that usually like he kind of
overplays things but it's like it you'd
think in a situation like that
if if anybody called for anything being
overplayed or you getting like super
upset you think that you being like anal
probe by aliens that would be the time
but i just love that he was just so yeah
blase about he almost winked at the
camera
he didn't have fun
to say something wink and [ __ ] yeah i
thought he was gonna do that because he
was [ __ ] smiling how dare you
have to have that put that [ __ ] metal
pipe up his ass he liked it it was like
the size of a damn vacuum cleaner hose
well and i like that the aliens had it
yeah that coming out of the wall like
one of those like high-end vacuum
cleaners like they used to have back in
the day where they installed them in the
wall like the central system yeah and
it's like so that kind of i was like oh
well that's that's very efficient just
in case you ever need your ass sucked up
on
look we have it right here it's right in
the wall it's with all the conveniences
of home right here on the alien
spacecraft yeah and you're [ __ ]
walking with this crazy ass hair
how dare you that was so that was such a
strange movie [ __ ] i mean
i had like i said i saw it a long time
ago but i kind of forgot i was like this
movie is batshit insane oh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's bad goes how dare you probe me
yeah yeah yeah
this is a good line for a shirt yeah
i'm mildly offended by that
he said what would i say to the alien
what would i say it would all depend on
the circumstances yeah what would what
would you say if you don't know what
they look like if they stuck a vacuum
cleaner up your butt i wouldn't it would
never happen
[Laughter]
kill me they'd have to do like what they
do with what they reported they
paralyzed you with the paralysis beam
and [ __ ] yeah
hell no man
i grew up in i grew up in i'm like khan
man we we grew up in in latino cultures
okay
[ __ ] you're ready to die for that you
know hell no you have to kill me all
right so that's way to happen
it would just i would mostly just react
depending on what the aliens look like
you know
they look [ __ ] up i'd say something
[Laughter]
but i'd be open-minded you know
you'd be open-minded yeah it'd be like
okay uh what kind of technology were you
guys from
[Laughter]
how's this ship work where are the keys
can i fly it yeah
just i'd have to see what the situation
was
yeah y'all [ __ ] got a starbucks
around here or whatever
which one of you is female how many
genders are we dealing with here that
would be that kind of [ __ ] how many
boobies do you hate well i just haven't
depends on what they look like you know
if if you go in there and they just look
like [ __ ]
seven foot diameter [ __ ]
spiders like some kind of damn
snow crab or something you know [ __ ]
deep seeing [ __ ]
crab i'm like i'm i'm [ __ ] out of
there
no
i'm doping the [ __ ] out of there like
nope
rick shaw says the hospital would never
believe me on how that hoover attachment
got in there it was aliens
i'm sure like some er doctors have heard
that like if you have to go to the er
like with something weird like shoved up
your butt yeah um
i'm sure that people have come up with
all kinds of crazy yeah and people do
like come in there with stuff shoved up
like look my sister used to do billing
for a gi clinic
and she's like yeah you'd be surprised
what ends up up people's asses
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure the concept of it of
aliens showing up and being in a
spaceship i'm pretty sure that's very
out of date that's probably not what it
is
you see these big flying triangle things
and the [ __ ] phoenix lights and all
that
it that [ __ ] is going to be
like a space vehicle
but it's more kind of like the monolith
out of 2001 there's no nothing
biological in there
it's going to be just a bunch of alien
souls inside they're
highly evolved and they're in like a
metaverse where they're like in a heaven
but they can also see out and they can
talk to other ones that are in other
ships and they don't have a planet they
just live in those things just one they
probably don't have much to do once
you're
that highly evolved
so you just stay in that ship
for safety
and it goes around and catalogs
everything maybe you try to help new
things grow
and then the rest of the time you're
the the if crew that's the population
the whole population of that species is
inside that thing
just their souls in there in a metaverse
you know so you never can't tell what
they'd be doing in there playing games
in the casino
having virtual sex
talking to each other
pretending to be other species that
they're not or just you know whatever
that'd be fun yeah
but they might be so sophisticated that
they're boring you know it might be that
too that they're just like a god-like
intelligence like something out of 2001
and they're just really imp impassive
you know
you know nothing to them way beyond
emotion and everything so they may not
be a very good quality of life from our
point of view you wouldn't want to do it
you probably wouldn't want to be one of
them
it'd be like a lamb living statue
a million years goes by and you'd even
notice it
didn't matter
you know whatever i'm definitely having
to do nothing yeah the stars big [ __ ]
deal
we're floating around the stars
shit's been going on for billions of
years
you know it's gonna be seen and seen it
it's always the same [ __ ] hated it yeah
right
like in the movie the signal oh yeah i
remember that i've seen it i didn't see
that i don't think you've seen it you'd
probably like that actually yeah it's
been a while since i've seen it but yeah
yeah it's gonna be something that you
would you couldn't relate to maybe you
should watch that yeah i don't know
because you know they're already talking
about these bill gates these [ __ ] egg
heads they should galaxy brains their
brains are so big they feel like those
guys they're already talking about
transhumanism
so they can be live forever in a video
game
inside their [ __ ]
mind box you know so they could have
heaven on earth and live in there
for millions of years which i'm not
opposed to it but i wouldn't mind that i
would only do that when at the end of my
life when the body starts giving out i
try that
you know but you you have to have an off
switch so if you go nah [ __ ] it i i
don't you know i've been in this here
for 200 years doing this [ __ ] i'm sick
of it you'd want to [ __ ]
be able to turn it off so you could die
yeah i mean i i would think that you
would need to have a fail safe because
otherwise people are just going to like
[ __ ] yeah right just to see if
there's a cause you can't make people
like keep doing that right right you
know right yeah hugo said the signal was
good i agree and uh as i said it's been
a while since i've seen it but i
remember really liking it probably you
would like it as well i don't know we
need to we need to find a movie tonight
to watch to talk about tomorrow um i
don't know if we could do the signal or
louis sent us that movie the accountant
yeah we see that we gotta watch let me
see that because they louis sent me that
in in
blu-ray so yeah he spent money so we'll
see that yeah we should probably watch
that tonight and i do actually want to
watch that john wayne gacy thing but
like i said
i can well i don't know how long that is
though all right so
i might have to like save that for
another night
uh let's see kaylen higgins says have
you guys read the three body problem it
kind of discusses the same things
regarding alien encounters with
technology beyond our comprehension yeah
i've heard about that but i haven't uh
haven't read it actually
uh i keep meaning to watch don't look up
yeah
i haven't seen that yet either although
everybody was talking about it a while
back so i'm sure i'll probably get
around to it i always forget like we
have netflix but i always forget because
we have so many other
streaming services usually like i'll hit
shutter or to be or amazon prime first
and i'm like oh yeah we have netflix too
maybe i should check that as well but we
have so many other and i have hulu so
i don't know because i guess i don't
check netflix as much because they tend
not to have as many horror movies and
i'm usually used looking for horror
movies
but
so that's usually not my go-to
hugo said i liked the accountant yes
maybe we'll watch that tonight because
like i said louis sent it to us last
week i think like on uh blu-ray or dvd
and i haven't seen it but everybody said
it's good something come to mind though
i was saying those aliens are probably
not biological because space travel
isn't conducive to it but if they are
biological they're a supreme
way high up on the evolutionary scale
which would mean it'd be like something
like the thing
and you wouldn't want to [ __ ] with that
that it absorbs everything that it comes
in contact with
and it takes these attributes i've
always said that and it can learn
anything just there is there's no alien
thing that would be scarier than
the thing i mean because yeah if that
came here we would all be fine you'd be
toast and as soon as something evolved
into that it would be a dominant species
yeah be unstoppable
yeah it would just proliferate probably
throughout the entire universe yeah and
if it ever came in contact with with a
high technological society which means
it would because it would be ancient
this thing it would have all of their
technology and knowledge
and have all that physical supremacy you
couldn't beat it nope
that's why like i said that's the
scariest alien so there might be
something like that out there that yeah
there might be something like that out
there
[ __ ] terrifying that's it might be on
its way here yeah that's worse than the
borg
from star trek much worse
camp guy says uh gacy is three one-hour
episodes okay so it's three hours long
so it's not as long as i thought it was
i was i was thinking it was gonna be
like some like six hours or eight hours
or something like that three hours isn't
too bad but yeah so maybe i don't know
maybe we'll watch it tonight or maybe
we'll watch it tomorrow i don't know but
uh yeah
so i guess we're gonna go we got some
dough
like ryzen yeah mister doughboy
and we're going to mix
it
got to keep on rising
[Laughter]
yeah we got some dough we're going to
we're going to make some pizzas and it
can be like the size of the air fryer
pillow
[Laughter]
so that'll be good yeah i'm starving
yeah okay but uh yeah all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by like i
said the deep house it's good if you
like haunted house movies um it's on
amazon prime and you can watch it on
there and tonight we're gonna watch the
accountant uh and thanks louie for
sending us that so we'll be back
tomorrow talking about that uh so thanks
for dropping by have a good rest of your
weekend and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow
bye